Fox News now going to a very negative
fox news story Fox News allowed lunatic
Christian Jerry Falwell Jr to suggest
that North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
may have created coronavirus as a weapon
to attack the United States we need to
listen to doctors we need to listen to
pandemic specialists we need to listen
to scientists on coronavirus we don't
need lunatic Christian preachers who
come from a line of lunatic Christian
preachers in their family like Jerry
Falwell Jr to go on television and say
these things and if they say them we
need them to be held accountable which
Fox News did not so this is a clip of
Christian pastor Jerry Falwell Jr
associated with Liberty University son
of the late Jerry Falwell senior who
once said 9/11 happened because of gay
people and abortions his son Jerry
Falwell Jr goes on Fox and Friends with
Trump regularly watches and remember
that and check out not just what he says
but how the Fox News clowns don't even
push back at all about it it's it's just
strange to me how so many are
overreacting the h1n1 virus in 2009
kills 17,000 people it was the flu also
I think and there was not the same hype
it was you just didn't see it on the
news 24/7 and it makes you wonder if
there's a political reason for that it's
it's you know impeachment didn't work
and and the Miller report didn't work
and and article 25 didn't work and so
maybe now this is their their next their
next attempt to get Trump but but I had
a the owner of a restaurant asked me
last night he said you remember the
North Korean leader promised a Christmas
present for for America
Becker it back in December could it be
they got together with China and this is
that president I don't know how but it
really is something strange going on
well Jerry so regarding the fact that
you're going to continue to have classes
people are overreacting there's too much
news coverage this is politicized
coronavirus is just like impeachment and
isn't it possible this was a weaponized
virus created by Kim jong-un and China
to attack the United States fascinating
Jerry and and you guys are continuing to
hold classes that's the reaction from
the Fox News people now let's go through
it at two layers at its face this is
absurd first and foremost but think
about it a little more deeply other
countries so far there's still time but
so far other countries have been hit way
harder than the United States Italy Iran
China Spain so why would Kim jong-un
punish the United States by creating a
virus that disproportionately kills
people in Europe and Asia at least for
now
every aspect of this appearance is
weaponized ignorant and it's
irresponsible
it's Infowars level stuff that is being
allowed on fox news i told you last week
attorneys general have been sending out
notices to people selling fake
coronaviruses like drinking silver they
should be sending out the same notices
of cease and desist to fox news for
allowing known disinformation to spread
which will cause panic and
misunderstanding and potentially cause
even more cases of corona virus and
deaths now one other thought to consider
Jerry Falwell is simultaneously saying
this is all an overreaction and it might
be a North Korean bioweapon think about
that for a second if this really was a
North Korean bioweapon aren't we
under-reacting
that would be insane and effectively an
act of war if it is the case that this
is a North Korean bioweapon we're not
overreacting we're drastically under
reacting but Fox News just says oh yeah
right and and you're continuing to hold
classes Jerry at Liberty University
fascinating fascinating they've all
failed us the people that elected Donald
Trump have failed us as he now is
completely in over his head
lying uncontrollably diarrhea of the
mouth can't tell it can't tell the truth
it's like Pinocchio with Donald Trump
except the more he lies instead of his
nose getting bigger his face becomes
more orange and meanwhile Fox News is
allowing this stuff and continuing to
have people on saying this is a great
time to fly the planes will be empty
this
a great time to go to nice restaurants
the restaurants will be empty these
people will be our undoing and we are
working against not only the virus but
we are working against the
disinformation viral spread that is
happening simultaneously